Continuing
[Silence]
in the chapter of patience of authored
We have a narration here on the
authority of an Malik. An Malik Abu
passed away in the year 92 or so after
Hijra.
Spiral
forch.
[Silence]
Here
we have a narration on the authority of
an
narration has
it's very concise as you've heard the
entirety of it in Arabic. However,
its meanings are immense and its lessons
are numerous.
And
tells us that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
once passed by a woman that was crying
at a grave.
And Sah Muslim the detail is added that
she was crying at the grave of a child
that had passed away of hers.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said to her now when we say crying it
wasn't just tears.
We know this how
because the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam shed tears over his
grandchildren that passed away. He shed
tears over his own children that passed
away.
Tears do not in any way interfere
or they do not in any way
necessitate that a person is not being
patient.
When the prophet sallallah.aii
Wasallam's son Ibraim passed away.
He said
he said indeed the eye does shed its
tears and the heart is sad. However, we
do not say anything that that we only
say what pleases the lord subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Now notice here the statement
we only say.
We only say
saying here is not just verbally with
the tongue. But saying in the Quran and
Sunnah is the heart and the tongue to
say you say with your heart. The heart
has sayings. Fear of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. Hope in Allah. Love of Allah.
These are sayings of the heart are
referred to as actions of the heart.
And so
shedding a tear, shedding tears, this
does not negate a person's patience,
legislative patience. It doesn't mean
that the person is not being patient.
So here when
says he w he passed by a woman who was
crying at the grave of a child of hers.
This does not mean that she was just
shedding tears. This means that she was
doing other things that do negate a
person's patience like
perhaps screaming or wailing or
doing these things that do negate a
person's patience. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam saw this and he
spoke out. He said,
he said, "Obey Allah, fear Allah, and be
patient."
And so she said to him,
"Leave me alone,
for you have not been afflicted with
what I have been afflicted with." Now,
at this point, she didn't know that she
was speaking to the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam. How could she not know
who the prophet is? Yes. Entire tribes
entered into Islam
and not every single individual person
had come to meet him. Sallallah.aii
wasallam.
this is very common when the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam went for Hajj his
first and final time he went for Hajj in
the ninth year after Hijra.
Alazi
the Muhamad Abu Z Abuazi
they mentioned that they were
contemporaries of Im Ahmed they
mentioned that about a 100,000
people were with him during that Hajj
did he meet every single individual
amongst them of course not he didn't
meet every one of them they didn't all
know him by faith
Right? Perhaps they had even seen him or
come to the masid. The masid is big and
they perhaps couldn't see all the way in
front. Not everyone got the opportunity
to intimately meet the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. So here she
assumes she's speaking to a regular
person from Medina who has told her to
be patient and she says to him, "Leave
me alone. You don't know what it's like
what I'm going through. You don't have
this problem. Well, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam had that exact
problem seven times in his life.
Wasam of his eight children. Seven of
them died in his lifetime. And before he
passed away, he was informed that his
last and final and most beloved child
would be the first of his companions to
pass away after him 6 months after his
death. And so the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam saw that she was inconsolable.
Inconsolable.
And so he left her be. He let her be. He
didn't continue the conversation or he
didn't continue. This is not a moment to
teach. This is not a teaching moment.
Why is it not a teaching moment? Because
the person he is speaking to is
emotionally charged.
And you cannot speak knowledge to
emotion.
Knowledge is spoken to intellect.
when a person is able to comprehend.
When a person is able to,
had he continued with his
guidance of her, maybe she would have
said even worse things out of
emotion. And so he's speaking to emotion
here. It's for instance, if you
were to imagine
a group of people that are protesting
and they are enraged and angry and
jumping on cars and burning things. If
himself came to speak to them at that
moment, they would not listen. Why?
Because this is emotion. These people
have been their minds right now are
being hijacked by emotion. And so he
left Sallallah.aii wasallam.
Afterwards
those who were around they said to her
that was the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. You just spoke to the one the
man who just said this to you and you
spoke to him in that way. That was
the prophet. And so obviously
immediately she
you know backtracked and and went out
looking for him to try to correct her
mistake to apologize.
And so she went looking for his home
where he would be. And when she got
there she found that he didn't have
She didn't find any guards at his door.
This is
strange. Why is it strange? Because
you've got a man that is feared by the
Romans and Persians. A man who is the
most influential human being with an
incredible amount of power but also an
incredible amount of enemies. Yet he
doesn't have any guards. Does this mean
that we should never have guards? No. It
is an issue of itchy head. If there's
a need for it, then yes, we'll have
guards. If not, there were other
instances where the prophet did have
guards sai wasam. He would have guards
through the entirety of every single
night on shifts in Medina saiam
until the verse in was revealed.
Allah will protect you from the assault
from being murdered by others. And so
after that he dismissed his guards saiam
this is specific to him. He is he is
specified to have had this and so
she entered and and said I didn't know
you when I said what I said. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam said to
her
now comes the lesson now the t the
teaching the knowledge why because now
he's speaking to
intellect he's not speaking to blind
emotion
and so he said
he said patience
truly is at the first
at at the first appearance or at the
first
startle of
hardship. When the hardship first comes,
that moment, that is when patience truly
is. And we will expound upon this
statement tomorrow, inshallah, because
it warrants much
commentary. This narration has been
collected by both Bkari and Muslim
subhanahu
and